nein ok alex von bunter machen wir
weiter mit der nächsten vielleicht wird
sich jetzt etwas klappt jetzt bekommen
beim neuen video ja wir haben heute
montag und endlich oder es mit montag
ich weiß es nicht so langsam vergess ich
irgendwie was den tag wir haben auf
jeden fall gibt es heute neues video von
mir und ich hab mir ungefähr vor einer
woche dieses video gemacht was jungs
machen und mädchen
andersrum ich habe auf jeden fall so
ungefähr vor einer woche ließ wieder
gemacht was mädchen machen und jungs
immer falsch verstehen und dadurch
gefragt er hat den bock auf dem zweiten
teil
und jetzt auf jeden fall also die
mädchen von euch hab wirklich so viele
kommentare geschrieben was die jungs
machen und ihre falsch versteht und die
schauen wir uns jetzt mal genauer an und
machen an das video dazu was jungs
machen und mädchen immer falsch
verstehen soll jetzt haben wir auch so
kurz bevor wir anfangen wenn die bock
habt noch weitere jungs mädchen themen
dann lasst genau jetzt mal doch noch um
dann sehe ich das hier schon mal und
schreibt in den kommentaren eure themen
die ich gern mal so besprechen sollte
von eurer seite er hat dann weiß ich
dass uns so viel was geiles raus und
jetzt viel spaß also jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt
stark wir doch einfach mal mit dem
ersten kommentar und der kommt von
miriam sie schreibt du bist schon wieder
in der schule zu kommen um den termin
mit der bitte an sie zu wenden da ich
die letzten tage nicht da ich nicht so
gut es nicht mehr beiträge von den
beiden anderen termin dankeschön miriam
für den kommentar und das ist wirklich
sollen sachen das verstehe ich bei
mädchen auch nicht du bist schon wieder
in der schule zu kommen um den termin
mit der bitte an sie zu wenden da ich
die letzten tage nicht da ich nicht so
gut ist nicht mehr mit beiträgen von
beiden anderen termin
miriam wenn du hilfe brauchst und
schreibe mir doch einfach bei instagram
oder so vielleicht kann ich helfen ich
weis machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
kommentar der sich jetzt bestimmt auf
das thema bezieht du redest zuviel idiot
und du siehst nicht hübsch aus
ok stop stop shop jetzt fangen wir
wirklich an
jetzt geht es rund also wir fangen mit
dem ersten kommentar und zwar celine
schreibt wenn jungs sagen schickt mal
ein bild von dir
ich denke dann immer hat das ihr eine
bestimmte art von bilder erwartet und
blog hier immer sofort her das verstehe
jetzt auch nicht was meinst du wort mit
irgendwelchen bestimmten bildern die
meint bestimmt zu bilder wo der junge
gerade am essen ist oder oder vielleicht
wo der jungen blatt sport macht oder so
ich weiß echt nicht was mit bestimmten
bildern meint spaß also ich kann ich da
wirklich verstehen ich verstehe nicht
wie man als junger so sachen schreiben
kann zu irgendwelchen mädchen so schick
mal bild.de schicksal bild gi auf
instagram guckt ihr bilder an fand der
person eigentlich oder nicht problem
gelöst kommen wir zum nächsten punkt
jedoch wirklich ziemlich viele likes und
zwar ich verstehe es einfach nicht wieso
jungs immer vor den kumpels einen auf
cool machen müssen und wenn sie alleine
mit dem mädchen hin auf einmal so süß
sind habe ich glaube ich schon 23 mal
beantwortet oder sei es nur ein mal
gewesen sein lassen tun wenn können aber
hey was ja das ist eine sache die tritt
wahrscheinlich mehr so auf wenn man
gerade so in der pubertät ist da ich mal
14 15 16 jahre dann sind jungs so ich
will jetzt auch wirklich gar kein blatt
vor den mund nimmt sondern einfach zu
sagen was ich dazu wirklich halte und
ich muss auch gestehen dass ich selber
wirklich so mit 14 15 jahren auch so war
dass ich vor jungs immer so cool sein
wollte und ich weiß nicht warum das so
ist aber das ist einfach so wisst ihr
das liegt einfach so in der jungs gehen
dass man so mit 14 15 16 jahren einfach
mal cool sein will vor seinen freunden
eda schreibt ich komme aus österreich
und schreibe im moment mit einem
deutschen jungen und dann schreibt er
auf einmal nah mit dem herz und ich habe
gedacht er sagt nein weil in meinem
dialekt heißt nein nein so geil ich
verstehe
gefällt dir dieses video what i net
witzig das ist natürlich eine sache weil
ich auf jeden fall sehr witziger ist das
gelesen habe war auf jeden fall witzig
als ich das gelesen habe
weil es fall witzig gelesen hab so
machen wir weiter und zwar schreibt die
lenis ich hasse es wenn jungs zu lachen
und du einfach nicht checks warum
ja man ist echt so wer weiß warum ich
das gemacht habe schreibt sie in die
kommentare das interessiert mich jetzt
voll witzig das macht mein ok alex vom
runter machen wir weiter mit der
nächsten vielleicht wird sich jetzt die
luisa schreibt mädchen denken wenn der
junge keine e modus in webshops schickt
dass ihr erfolg von ihr genervt ist
das versteht man als mädchen nicht
falsch das ist so ich meine jungs
schreiben jetzt vielleicht nicht so
viele smileys wie mädchen
aber wenn man das wie schreibt dann ist
da auch schon irgendwas dran so und man
ist vielleicht genau das kommt natürlich
dann auch individuell auf jeden
einzelnen jungen an das will ich jetzt
nicht verallgemeinern weil nachher
kriegt dann wieder ärger von ihr gewinn
von euch und das bitte ich auch tief als
dass man jetzt einige kommentare ich
hoffe dieses video ausgefallen wenn ihr
bock habt auch noch ein teil oder so
schreibt es auf jeden fall in die
kommentare und lasse mir genau jetzt
wann dann nach oben da würde mich sehr
freuen
für einfach weitere jungs mädchen themen
und wir sehen uns dann am mittwoch beim
neuen video wieder mittwoch kommt meines
video ich freue mich auf euch dass ihr
ein zu helles und haut rein
dies wollten wir auf instagram da heißt
ich alex w